Yeah, there's nowhere to hide. That's
why I love the store so much. Yeah,
there's so many places to hide, but the
store has that little problem with the,
or like when you,
right before you're about to go on stage,
you're in the hallway and he had only
the hallway but I liked the seats on
against the back that just for comics do
you kind of sit there and go over your
notes and I believe you learn. I love that
Backbar, that backbone is my favorite.
The back bars, the shit,
the secret comedians bar.
I mean that's just what
they've done in the new,
this new generation of managers and the
people that run the place now David sort
of like really paid
attention to like what,
what's going to make these guys happier?
What's going to make this better?
Like you got to give them a
place where they can hide.
So giving that back bar and you go to
the back bar any day it's filled with
people just hanging out, talking shit
and like it's fun. It's like a fun play.
I go there, I gravitate and I get
into the back end. I'm like, oh look,
all these cool people. Yeah, this is a
great spot to hang out it. Yeah, yeah.
They did that. They added
security. They did it. So it's,
it's night and day two the way it used
to be. Oh, I never used to go there.
I didn't like hanging out there. I didn't
like any part of it. And then once, uh,
once the new management took
over, I was like, oh great.
Like I once did a show there, I did a
benefit. There was like a kid who died,
I forget his name, he was a comic, uh,
died in a car accident and they had
like a benefit for his family. Oh yeah,
that's job shout Myers friend
Angelo. Yeah, Angelo about it.
I did not know him. I didn't
know him either, but a bike's,
he was like a fan of mine and I was like,
I was like his favorite comic they
could get. And I'm like on the,
I'm on the marquis,
it's a sold out show.
I have a great set of walk off and
Tommy comes up and he's like, ah.
The old manager was like, aunt,
that was great when we got,
we've got to get you around. You
got to start hanging out, you know,
you got to start hanging out and doing,
you know, doing the open mic and stuff.
And I'm like, dude, tell me open my,
my name is on the marquee right now.
You just watched me headline this
show. Like, what are you talking about?
And I then,
I don't think I ever saw him again.
Next thing I knew he was
fired and they were like,
what can we do to get you back here?
But I love it. Well that's Adam, right?
Adam did the same thing to me.
He told me that Tommy got fired
and came to visit me. The improv.
So you were gone seven years,
seven years from the store and then when
Tommy left they brought you back in?
Yeah, well there's two reasons. One,
I had to go physically to the store
because Ari was filming his comedy central
special and is like that.
He's a,
you know,
Ari's just one of my best friends and I
knew him from the time he was a doorman
and I knew that him filming his special
there was so important and there's no
way I was going to miss it. I
was like, I have to be here,
like I have to see this at the store.
So I was like, oh fuck. All right,
I've got to go back.
And so I decided to go back.
I think he was filming on a Wednesday.
What night is a gross battles on Tuesday,
right? So I went down
there on a Tuesday. I said,
let me go down on Tuesday
just to see what's up.
And I went to roast battle and I was
like, Holy Shit, this place is electric.
This is crazy. Like the environment is
so much different. It's so creative.
And the, the night that I was at
roast battle was fucking fantastic.
It was so good. There was so many funny
roasters and I remember thinking, wow,
this place is just different, man.
It just feels so much different.
And it wasn't like it is now.
Like now,
like you'll go on a Saturday night,
they'll have six sold out shows.
They have two shows in the belly room too,
in the or two in the main room.
Everything's sold out and packed
with headliners and it's chaos.
It wasn't like that.
It was still sort of Shitty,
like in terms of like the numbers,
but the vibe and the
creativity was way different.
And the new guys and
girls that were coming up,
they were fucking good man. I was
like, wow, this is a different vibe.
I had been gone for almost a decade. Yeah.
So that brought me in and like I said,
I had to be there for Ari.
There's no way.
There's no way I could miss it. I had
to be there. So I'm like, all right,
I just got to swallow it. And that was
probably what Adam for sure helped,
but I might've stayed away forever if
it wasn't for Ari. I just had to see it.